[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to
gamespot.com whoa my hair is doing
something cool
uh we are on Mega bit uh a show where uh
myself sometimes Maxwell and other
co-workers play old video games today we
are playing Mega Man X and as part of
today's stream we are also Fielding
submissions for a giveaway for a replica
Mega Man helmet that came from Comic-Con
it's not a full-size helmet it's about
well it might fit on a cat if you have a
small cat but it's really heavy it's
made of really good material so if you
want to enter to win that we're going to
be giving it away later this week but in
the meantime what you need to do is
Photoshop a Mega Man helmet onto a cat
onto a photo of a cat rather and uh
submit that they have a real cat you can
take a picture of oh wait no you said
photo no yeah well yeah sure you can
take a picture of your own cat and on
yeah uh so anyway Photoshop Mega Man
helmet onto a cat uh send it to me via
Twitter and a Gamespot so my handle is
PC Brown and then obviously at Gamespot
and later on this week we'll choose a
winner let's say Thursday is the day we
will decide so you guys have a few days
to put these together and yeah we will
ship that out to you uh Max I saw that
Mega Man helmet you were talking about
it had it came on like a little tiny
stand and there was like a Mega Man one
and a protoman one they're not that tiny
I'll be honest with you they looked
really small in the picture they look
like that big the stand is about this
tall mhm the helmet is about that big
okay and the whole so you might be able
to squeeze a cat head in there yes if
you don't care about your cat's
happiness let's say um the whole thing
weighs about five to six pounds
something like that in the meantime
let's get to the game there it is
there's a shot of it hey there it is
yeah it's really sweet and so the bass
lights up with USB power of course it
does if you notice his little uh ear
things also light up covers yeah and and
that sort of like a passive uh thing
like when you put it on the stand did
you say it they light up say what how
heavy it was like five six pounds okay
when and that's like without the like
just the helmet I want to say maybe with
the stand but it's it's people when they
hold it they're like who what is this
got some good heft okay so yeah when you
put the helmet on the stand those ear
things sort of light up on their own
which kind of a cool little effect
that's NE uh no cables necessary the
meantime we're going to get started here
Max you're going to hate me we're we're
starting from scratch let's go back to
zero we're starting from scratch all
right uh Mega Man X as you can see came
out in 1993 it was sort of capcom's way
of I don't want to say Reviving Mega Man
because Mega Man was still popular they
were bringing Mega Man into the the new
generation
yeah basically yeah I mean uh I mean
what's weird is actually Mega Man 6 came
out I want to say after Mega Man X or
like right around the same time as the
on the NES probably um but yeah Mega Man
X is sort of a a higher Tech take on
Mega Man it sort of delves into this
like future where Maverick these sort of
uh Al so it's you have the Mavericks oh
there's a it's a whole thing right right
so but Mega Man X is one of the
Mavericks right or he's a hunter he's a
Maverick Hunter he's a Maverick Hunter
Maverick so Maverick as I understand it
is sort of like a disase disas that
robots can come down with you become
Maverick you you're not built as a
Maverick um and they sort of alludes to
it here in the intro where it's like
Mega Man X is super powerful he might
somehow break the rule of don't kill
humans yeah which we're going to get to
right here yeah which as far as I
understand is sort of like the essence
of what it is to be a Maverick you
basically just hate humans at that
point um yeah this was a pretty great
this is a pretty great little intro
sequence it freaked me out a little bit
as a kid cuz it's just like red flashing
lights Danger warning and I thought and
you know I as a kid I completely bind in
the fiction of whatever game this is I'm
like oh no this what is this game like
really dangerous or something what is
this or is like the FBI going to come
knocking at the door is this one of
those like don't copy a video game
warning
screens I don't know I was pretty easy
to dup as a kid guess they uh what do
they make eight Mega Man X Games oh
goodness yeah I think they I think they
did stop at 8 I don't think they made it
up to 9 Mega Man X1 it got really weird
Mega Man X through3 were on Super
Nintendo and after that they had Mega
Man X 4 and five on PlayStation and then
are both good I think six was on
Playstation as well but then like seven
and eight and then there were even some
other offshoot ones on PS2 that
incorporated 3D in really weird ways but
Mega Man X is one of the better ones
apart from being the first which one of
the best Mega Man games by far
yeah you want to lead it off you yeah
I'll start start off I'll play the intro
stage Max you have a lot Mega Man X
knowledge some L it on us uh well as
we're going to see here one of the big
Innovations for Mega Man X was the
Advent of scrolling screens also also
maybe there should have been a secret
back there trying totally not not a
thing I could do but as you can see oh
look at this the screen just
Scrolls I don't know maybe they had that
in an older magman game um well no you
would go screen to screen right yeah you
would go it would go it would be on a
fixed screen and then you'd hit some
sort of barrier and it would slide over
to the next screen whereas in Mega Man X
just one just continuous thing uh X's
ability or Mega Man's abilities have
also changed like he has the ability to
wall jump Mega Man and X are you were
correct they are different characters X
is not an improved version of Mega Man
Mega Man I guess is dead or obsolete or
otherwise has otherwise been
discontinued in this timeline and now we
have X who is his own individual
persona
there we go I've just been
handed if you guys have any questions
about that Mega Man helmet or the
giveaway uh hit up Us in the twitch chat
or the Gamespot chat if you're watching
on our
site uh yeah it's a pretty it's a really
sweet helmet the the blue one is limited
I think to
1,50 so like they only made a really
limited number of those there's another
one that was exclusive to comc con that
was red for like Mega Man's Rush mode
variant
uh that one will not be on sale after
Comic-Con I think if they have any
remaining blue ones you can buy those
from Capcom site but there's a chance
those are already sold out more than
likely more than likely knowing knowing
Capcom and knowing Comic-Con exclusives
or limited runs they're probably all
gone and will be up on eBay for $600
later this week yeah I mean I saw people
selling them for twice their sticker
value the day that we picked ours up so
wonderful
you dash straight away no you got to
pick it take the boots first you got to
get that in the chill penguin stage one
of the great things about Mega Man X is
how it teaches you the rules of the game
through it stage design there's a really
great video on YouTube say it's by ego
raptor is about youo rap you think of
his his two maybe three SQL I think he's
done three Now sequelitis videos that
he's done and the first one was on
talking about Mega Man oh fell right in
that hole damn it yeah after to a good
start I could have sworn I hit that J
button comparing uh Mega Man X to
traditional Mega Man's and how good this
opening stage is at teaching players
stuff I remember one of the ones that
stood out to me is something I
completely didn't notice is when you uh
when you fight one of those be
helicopters helicopter looks like a
bumblebee that you fought twice um when
you fall down into the pit after you
defeat it the uh the structure of the
helicopters in such a way that it's sort
of if you just run over it you'll run
into the wall and start sliding down the
wall and the game just very sub shows
you that hey you can stick to walls now
maybe if you hit the jump button oh look
at that now you're climbing out of the
hole Yeah and even in the chill penguin
stage I forget if Eoraptor talk about
this but it right before you get the
ability to Dash You're presented with a
series of platforms where you're like oh
man it's like just Out Of Reach like if
only I had a way to get over there
anyway and get oh there we go then you
make it and it's like you don't have to
clap for
making uh that was a very condescending
clap I apologize it was it was that's
fine it's Monday yeah then you get then
you get the dash boots and you're like
oh man oh now I'm now I'm just my
prayers have been answered alling ass
all over the place this thing drops two
cars on me and then it's like oh wait
and they put me against vile is that his
name yep if you're a real cool kid
though you can not a cool kid you can uh
you'll destroy the driver but then jump
onto the car yeah and then it rides you
around but it won't but it'll only go
One Direction it won't turn
around yeah here we
see not the true antagonist of Mega Man
X but one of them
yeah vile in his power armor being
awesome just being a boss all over Mega
Man also not a battle I can win nothing
nothing you can do about it there you go
you get
captured and then something else you
after pointed out here a really good bit
of foreshadowing coming
up really great way to start the story
we see our villain doing something
villainous and then Here Comes oh what
is that oh what's that sound uhoh uhoh
no that's not Proto man that's not it's
future Proto
man so zero comes in like a boss blows
off the dude's arm in like one hit X is
like I whoa I cannot even you are so
awesome how do I how do I be as awesome
as you Zero's like it's cool man not
everybody be as cool as big papa zero
not everyone can have Big Daddy Z an
amazing blonde ponytail an amazing
blonde ponytail in the sweet red armor
see you later
so I want to say it was X3 that you
first got the chance to play as zero you
did in a very limited capacity cuz
spoiler spoiler at the end of this game
zero sacrifices himself to destroy uh uh
vile's Power Armor oh during the vile
fight um and so he's dead in Mega Man
X2 but in X3 he's back for whatever
reason um and you can you he's sort of
like this God mode power up that you can
activate um but it's super limited right
like once you die you don't get to use
him again until the next stage I'm
trying to remember like I think if you
just activating him whether you die or
not I believe just that's it that was
your like turn to use zero um if you
save him up though and you get to like
you get to sigma's Fortress and you get
to a particular boss fight in sigma's
Fortress and bring out zero and and cuz
that's sort of like the cut off point is
that particular boss fight so whether
you win or lose there zero gets damaged
and is forced to retreat but he'll give
Mega Man his his beam saber as he does
in this game if you if you have all the
upgrades I believe um but yeah that was
sort of the first time so you could like
take him out in like a trial mode sure
you could take for a test
drive he can shoot charge shots all over
the screen he had a sword he could Dash
all over the place he was so much he was
just so much awesomeness um but yeah but
then in X4 they toned him down a whole
lot and made him into his own character
so Mega Man X sort of the very adaptable
Fighter um sort of the the Ryu in our
Mega Man Universe um definitely more of
a range fighter as well whereas zero has
is all about the beam saber CU that's
what makes him awesome so he has very
limited uh projectile options and all of
his stuff is melee this is that platform
I Su right here where you're like okay
like well how can I if only I could a
little bit easier a little bit on
there but seriously what the hell you
got to get up
there uh why isn't this working you got
to get like right on the edge of it well
I I understand that that that part is
not a mystery is this where you had that
weird glitch too when you were on the
Retron no so yeah I was playing on the
Retron 5 and later on in this stage I
fired my Buster at just like a random
object the game froze and then it
informed me hey you just unlocked the uh
the the chill penguin weapon you beat
the boss I was like what no was in the
middle of stage no I didn't there's been
a horrible mistake so then it kicked me
out and it put me back in the intro
stage of the game with the ice weapon
that's when I said all right we need to
use the Retron 3 because this is
insane uh there's no telling what other
glitches would have appeared uh so yeah
this is Dr Light from the distant past
talking to you through a princess Dr
Light has made a lot of these capsules
and he spread them all over the world as
if he somehow foresaw not only one or
two or three but like
multiple robot uprisings and the need
for his capsules to come back time and
again it's true very forward thinking
that Dr
Light Dr light's first name starts with
a t let me guess it's I think I believe
it's Thomas I believe I believe Canon
has stated that Dr light's first name is
in fact Thomas his name is Thomas light
so yeah now you've got the dash boots
you can Dash around the screen like a
boss there you go you can jump all over
everything that guy will totally push
you into that hole he laughs too I love
this so many of the enemies have these
little facial these little facial ticks
that like that right there where they
totally laugh at you um if they hit you
or if you mess up little things like
that are great and it makes you hate
them that much more and want to shoot
them with your Mega
Buster CH penguin is the stage I always
started on also this was great right
here you get to see the power armor in
the intro stage and then in the chill
penguin stage you get to try it out
yourself pow like a boss oh punch that
dude oh you could go up there but you
have to abandon the power armor yeah and
that's actually where the glitch
happened oh okay there I tried I tried
to get on the Retron 3 was not
pre-produced there is a heart canister
up there but you can't get to it until
you have flame Mammoth weapon you got to
melt some [__] so that'll be one of the
last ones I will get yeah Ice Penguin a
good stage to start on is the stage I
always start on um but I know you could
also start with flame Mammoth um he's
also an acceptable place to start but if
you do chill penguin first when you go
to Flame mamath stage like since he's
the flame guy there's all these pools of
lava and fire everywhere and if you go
to his stage after being chill penguin
all those pools of lava and stuff are
all frozen over so it actually makes the
stage a lot easier I've never seen that
and that kind of blows my mind actually
yeah you can you can go look at it after
you do this assuming I can do this I
couldn't do it earlier you had to do it
you got to hug the wall yeah but just
just knowing that is not
enough also you can only you can
basically only hit CH penguin once
before cuz like you'll hit him and he'll
blink for a while and then he'll start
his next attack and by that point yeah
you'll want to be out of the
way
oh what a dick oh I sat on your face so
fast all right what's going on
[Music]
chat one of the really subtle things I
like about Mega Man X is that so when
you go into a boss room if you start
charging up your weapon and you go
through the door and it like does a
little screen freeze and you see Mega
Man doing the funny pose it'll hold your
charge without you having to hold down
the button so you can charge it up start
walking through the door and as the
little animations are playing you can
let go of that charge button and as soon
as the fight starts Mega Man will just
let it rip on his first shot and uh get
a hit in on the enemy pretty
quickly again a really minor thing but I
like
it you got chill penguin come up
here no just going to cough it up cough
it
up run through there nope just do it I
can't I can't shoot I I guess I could I
think if I shoot him enough they will
break all right send
the so I didn't realize you could knock
him off
there that would have been
useful Char do it do it do it there you
go that doesn't extend to far there
that's the pattern I want to
see no should have gone for the green
shot boom I was like seven or eight
years old this game came out and I
didn't have a Super Nintendo my buddy
did and he got this and I knew Mega Man
but I was really confused cuz I was like
so this Mega Man 10 s he like no like
what where all the other where's Mega
Man
789 he like didn't he couldn't explain
to me that it was like a like a sub
Series yeah I
offo ivly figured it out pretty quickly
but at the time I was like I don't get
it what happened to 78 n exactly exactly
capc oh password systems m one of my
favorite things is uh you would rent
Mega Man X from the store right and
you'd bring it home and they always have
the notes section in the back and
somebody would have some written random
password scribbled down in there and you
load that up and see where they were at
see where they were at that was always
fun so after sort of picking where you
want to start basically it then just
becomes following boss weapon weaknesses
so spark Mandel here is weak against
chill pinguin ice shotgun or whatever it
was so we'll go
to had no idea what a mandrel was as a
kid I was like what the hell is this
he's got got all these colorful lights
he's maybe like a monkey looking thing
but he's got these huge shoulders what
is it uh rhythm is asking how old I am
I'm 29 years old thanks for asking Max
you are 27 uh uh be 27 in August all
right very very
soon this guy too also I always think
he's laughing at me so like see he gets
up there
[Music]
like think you're awesome I'm Mega Man
you're awesome [__]
Mega also spark Mel stage one of the
best not the best but one of the best
soundtrack or stage themes in this
game little guitar riff right
there it's so good it's so good we were
uh when we were at Comic-Con over the
weekend we were standing outside just on
a balcony outside of our production room
anyway there was uh someone was playing
like old school songs in the background
and we had already planned to play Mega
Man X and lo and behold the intro of
theme music for Mega Man X oh nice and I
was super excited and Dan a good om Dan
mahor production had no idea why I was
excited bless his
heart now what are you going to do there
you
[Music]
go oh he's oh he's on the Move now okay
okay Max I'm going to distract you
they're talking about Initial D in the
chat o did you ever watch initial
I see I never watched any Initial D I've
seen I would see like pictures of it pop
up on image boards and stuff and I
always thought the character designs
looked really weird that's that's I
couldn't watch it because of that and it
turned me it turned me off to the series
but I loved the super cheesy jpot music
cuz all the music's just like midnight
love forever and then shots at him like
driving the
car I'm like oh this is really good I'm
into this but yeah never watched I dug
the whole like car based narrative and
the racing and all that but the yeah
everyone was drawn in the strangest way
possible it made no sense no one else
was doing any art that
way I guess it made it stand out yeah
but not in a good way in like a really
bad way cuz they all had these like
weird lips they
did thin narrow eyes it was man it was
weird yeah it freaked me
out fly down here apparently there's
some pretty good arcade games though
that Sega made mhm racing games didn't
we did we play one of them or was that
Marco georgevich who played one of them
it was probably Marco
geovic ex editor cuz I think yeah cuz we
played that at uh I guess it was before
your time we played that at Joy uh in
Japan somewhere um it was like this big
arcade um and they had a bunch of games
that like you would sit inside and do
things um yeah I know right and one of
them was an initial Dame uh where you
sat inside of a little a tiny little
play ftic car um and you tried to drift
down a mountain and he was really
terrible at it but to be fair the game
looks super hard um and it did play
awesome J-pop techno music so I was on
board all that there is a initial drk
machine in San Francisco I think it's at
it's in the Metrion theater I want to
say or no no no it's at the the AMC on
vs oh okay which means so much to all
you out there yeah you guys all know the
AMC on vaness it's okay it's not as good
as the Metro it's okay
uh worker is asking did Sega have
something to do with the Mario Kart
arcade games I want to say that was
Namco that was Namco that was a joint
that was a joint Namco Nintendo Jam yeah
yeah one of if not their first actually
Mario Kart arcade or Mario Kart GP right
it
is Mega Man X I
remember gosh so I had a I had a Sega
Genesis growing up I was one of those
people
um and I rented a Super Nintendo from my
local video establishment magic
video um and it came in this big it's
like a briefcase right it came in a huge
black plastic briefcase and I thought
that was just that was I felt like a
secret agent like it was the like it was
the foot the presidential football or
something that was being handed yeah we
were able to rent like what did I rent I
rented a Nintendo 64 and a virtual boy
at one point from the Blockbuster nearby
they had a virtual boy set up in the
store always had a line but you could
rent it if you could convince your
parents to throw down a massive deposit
and then you take it home and they be
like oh God what if I give it my
child just like putting your face in
that
thing oh am I shaking that I I have this
tick where I I just shake my foot
whenever I sit um which isn't bad in
itself but now the whole couch is
shaking all good I implore you
please
yeah I played Mega Man X on that giant
briefcase that was a pretty amazing
experience for young Maxwell so let's
see we got uh lightning that takes us to
armadillo you want to do armadillo stage
armadilla stage is one of my favorites
because it's got all the mine carts oh
and if anyone knows meab bit they know I
love Minecarts oh and Peter's great with
Minecart
sequences make sure we give him the
minecart stage uh right before Dreamcast
came out I was able to rent doing it
again I was able to rent the Dreamcast
in like August okay um Hollywood Video
had like a deal with Sega and they were
they were renting them out early yeah
it's pretty cool I thought the only game
you could get was Sonic Adventure that
of course I want I want to say it was
like limited to the to the one and you
you got that sequence where you see the
dolphin crashing through the docks and
everything like oh this is amazing it's
going so fast yeah Sonic Adventure was
one of the best launch games like that
in Mario go down as like best launch
games really great in history in
history
all the
health that guy I think if you climb up
that wall and get behind him there's
just like a little Health pick up back
there then there's also yeah there's a
health T you have to have the helmet to
break those
rocks speaking of helmets I hate those
guys I hate those guys so much too they
always they wait for like the wor they
takes they either take a really long
time or they always pop out in the most
inopportune time imaginable it's not
just on some sort of fixed timer they're
the [__] Medusa heads of Mega they
are the Medusa heads of Mega Man oh
they're the worst and they're not only
you know what are they oh that would be
interesting to see I bet they're the
only enemy that carries over from
original Mega Man into Mega Man
X it's possible it's possible just get
up
there they have stood the test of time
as some sort of useful construction
robot
I like this too cuz you can you shoot
your pellets and then you can almost
catch up with them you're almost faster
than a speeding
bullet there you
go can just troll
him cuz this enemy he's got SP he's got
go through he will kill you in one hit
if
you if his if you spikes hit you oh if
only yeah I don't think you're getting
that Health tank cuz he he chops the
Rocks down that you would need to boost
yourself up that's
okay we can't all be
healthy do an unhealthy
run this part here yeah when they start
putting the birds on the screen now this
n starts to
chug hold on hold on there's a lot of
dudes on the
screen want to yeah so later on in the
game game or do you want to tell it oh
go for it later on in the game if you're
a real cool dude and have all the
upgrades and the Heart tanks and the E
tanks and the armor and uh you have full
health as well you can climb up that
wall and there's a possibility that a
special light canister will be up there
and Dr Light will come out in a little
in a little ryugi and uh say some words
and then give you the uh the hoken from
Street Fighter which will just decimate
anything it touches WSS he why don't you
do this we don't have to start
over might be able to be you should be
able to bounces all over the place he's
a real bouncy boy it's hard to tell
where he's going to
go people in the chat are talking about
Neo Geo consoles yeah uh I'm sure you
remember about a year ago I was on
Craigslist at like 7 a.m. and behold
some guy puts up an ad for a so-call
broken Neo Geo home system oh right yes
I remember that uh with three games and
two joysticks for 20 bucks and uh he
lived like a couple streets away from me
so I met the guy after work I got his
broken Neo Geo M took it home opened it
up cleaned it out it's a working Neo Geo
yeah it totally was that was an amaz and
you got it for $20 for premium $20 not a
premium but for a deal for a really
really good deal it came with three
games two controllers the whole thing
was just like an incredible day and I
think I remember no one else was home
the time when I did it so when it
finally worked I was like yes just
running through yeah
yeah I did
it well we died on armadilla I'm going
to get I'm going to get flame Mammoth a
shot yeah but see look oh snow snow on
the ground and look this thing is
supposed to be fire and it kills you
when you land on it but now it's
frozen you can just skirt through this
incredible so but here's my question how
does that act I mean like in what way
does defeating a robot in a different
stage I'm talking about in The Narrative
of world in narrative okay how does
doing that then impact an entirely
different
location CU it's not like you're
releasing ice into the World by beating
chill penguin you're just beating a guy
who happens to be kind of cold well I
mean in the Mega Man X fiction they
always said if you have the helmet you
go up there to get the arm upgrade yeah
is is are the third dimensions in the
Mega Man X world just a series of planes
and depending on which plane is in front
of you that's the one that these are
actually all alternate realities that's
what we're getting here um no uh the way
I see it and the way that I think they
explain is that each of the each of the
M every robot who goes Maverick in the X
Games they always had some sort of job
or responsibility before that happened
so I think it's something where like
chill penguin like flame mammoth's in
charge of like this Refinery type place
right and chill penguin was in charge of
some sort of refrigeration or I don't
know ice research something or other
basically like you defeat penguin his
whole state like his whole area gets
damaged because you you go through there
and you're blowing everything up
shooting everybody so like maybe
whatever coolant leaks out yeah
Refrigeration type technology he was
working on becomes damaged and now this
stage maybe since it's this Refinery
relies on that technology um but we're
just left to assume all this I'm sorry
you know this narrative has too many
holes five out of 10 give a five out of
10 just go ahead five out of 10 plot
holes uh solid game play yeah but
narrative 5 out of
10 fun Factor holy [__] holy cow the fun
Factor through the
roof see I like this too cuz like it's
some sort of robot processing and
Manufacturing place they have conveyor
belts they have robots I'm doing the
foot thing again if I uncross my legs it
should help cuz it's because I have my
foot up there and I can see
it whoa yeah they definitely go into the
narrative more cuz like the first three
games they in the series they basically
kind of touch on it they give a little
intro a little outro Mega Man X4 kind of
has like a whole series of cut scenes
and really goes into like you're you're
on this team and you're kind of you know
fighting these guys and I won't get into
too much more than that but yeah I
appreciate the story more or
less that's my favorite of the door
poses this like his boxing pose like all
right I don't have the weapon fight some
fun things you can do with Mammoth uh if
you
have I don't know how to say the guy's
name but Boomer Kanger weapon kangar I
don't know how you say it but basically
the guy who gives you the little knife
that spins around um if you use that on
flame Mammoth it doesn't do any extra
damage but it will cut off his trunk so
he won't be able to use certain attacks
like this oil one that he's using on me
right he's going to jump over here any
he second it
now I'm not getting up up quickly um but
you can do that and then I think uh
Mammoth is actually weak to storm Eagle
weapon not the ice weapon not actually
not the ice weapon because uh spark
mandrel was weak to the ice weapon yeah
but there's there's a chance it'll still
do more damage in your Buster
though so he does this little thing
where he goes and it makes the platform
I'm standing on change directions oh
he's going to hit me
shot see what happens here I'm going to
hand this off to you Max BBB bulldozer
says that M man X4 is where the series
started to go down here Triple B
bulldozer I know you're a big uh you're
a big fan of X4 I really like X4 I
played I got about halfway through X4 I
what didn't you like about
it I know it's hard to put my finger on
um I really didn't like the uh
the jet Stingray stage where you're on
the
car yeah that one was pretty brutal I
didn't yeah that one that one was a
little rough
um which is weird cuz I'm trying to cuz
I I actually really liked
X5 what um but that had all those that
had all those crazy like staircase
levels I hated those it did um and it
might be because I haven't played X5
since like the first time I played it
forever ago so I just remember
remembering it too
fondly U but yeah I
mean I would say
so by the time X4 and X5 are done even I
mean you could still say X4 was where
the series went downhill without X4
actually being a bad game it's just sort
of the Turning Point [__] and games
after that got bad
[__] oh clipped you with his ears big
old ears not always the
way all right uh we're going to take a
quick break we will be right back in a
few minutes we're going to try to beat
this boss and hopefully by the time
you're back well maybe we beat him all
right we're back and we're still
fighting that boss still doing it still
doing it so max if we cannot beat him
here where to next uh then I guess we'll
try storm Eagle I think I think you can
get him though I think you got a good
you got a good pretty good
shot oh watch outp of that oil I thought
yeah I thought you got stuck in the oil
but I guess that's not true
oh I was too far away to get the hit on
that jump peace
out I know it's so
good oh no this is a poor idea I should
have jumped over you got him though you
got him yeah I don't he won't be able to
hit me on the
jump do it do it and then we jump over
him unrelenting Fury come on shut up
here we go shut up shut up shut
up all right now we if we had done this
earlier we could actually take so chill
penguin and Flame Mammoth have a nice
little relationship because if you do
chill penguin first and go to Flame
Mammoth his stage is all freezed over
but if you start with flame Mammoth and
then go to CH penguin you get the yeah
you can get the heart tank and you can
you actually use flame mammoth's weapon
against CH penguin that's what he's
actually super easy weak to
yeah
the flame weapon is also great for
blowing up those Masher things that are
in armadillo stage so let's actually I'm
gon to piece out and grab
that and then we'll try armadillo again
see what that chat be talking
about there's a lot of really great uh
fan theories online about cuz the X
serus has always been a little bit koi
um about Zero's Origins so like Dr Light
built Mega Man X but who H who
constructed zero where did he come from
um and they've done basically everything
except come flat out and say that Dr Wy
in fact build
zero Dr Wy did build zero yeah is that
is that really a surprise though but I
don't think they've actually said it
straight up in the cannon they always
just hint and allude at it and they'll
show like the wly look I think in one of
the games maybe X4 maybe X5 you if
you're playing as X you have a a fight
against like a mind controlled zero and
there's the big Wy logo in the
background the big Wy W throughout the
fight and you're like oh well I wonder
what that means jumping G Willers
speaking of Wy though Sigma the sort of
like head bad guy in in the X Series oh
my god dude anytime you have to fight
Sigma those are like for me the Hardesty
Mega Man battles of all time especially
in X4 they're marathons oh at the end of
X4 Sigma is massive and just has so much
Firepower it's really hard to deal with
I know and he's always got he always I I
love his progression of forms cuz he'll
have some sort of like underling that
you fight first and you fight Sigma and
he's like in his robot dude form and
sometimes he has an energy sword or
something and you're like okay this you
know he's tough and he's really fast but
like it's manageable cuz he's he he
moves and acts a lot like the other
bosses you fought so far and then you
blow that one up and you're like okay
great I did it but you haven't done it
at all and then turns into like some
sort of screen filling robot monstrosity
massive with like a sigma head yeah with
a just a tiny little Sigma head and then
he's just filling the screen up with
rockets and missiles and bull crap that
you have to you say tiny but an X4 man
he his head was like the oh is that the
one where it was like the huge 3D thing
of his head sort of yeah it was crazy it
was like the wire frame the green wire
frame was in his
head no I want to say maybe that was a
different one there's that heart tank
heart tank and peace out
yeah people are talking about money
number nine I watched some of the uh the
footage that they released okay uh
sample gameplay are they doing a show
they are doing a show that's what the
new crowd funding is for have you seen
that footage of money number nine uh
just a little bit that run
animation really that's right we're
going straight straight there no no no
just let me what's wrong with it what's
break it down for me very pronounced
movement for very little like distance
travel okay and it's almost like that's
the thing you see the most in that game
you're coning you're constantly moving
and he just runs kind of like a
goof and I know it's a really small
thing like get upset about right here
cuz we only have we're at zero lives
have foures but oh
man oh man I don't know describe it to
me show me sitting down what does his
run look like it's just like a like a
really it's like a power jog yeah about
that arm movement got to get your heart
rate up but not that like his torso like
rotates a lot when he runs it's just
it's too much I kind remember that now
you mentioned he like throw he's
throwing his shoulders around and like
going side to side as
he well hopefully that'll be the only
thing the only we can slide against it
yeah um also I want to remind people
that we will be giving away one of those
uh limited edition uh replica helmets
Mega Man replica helmets from Capcom um
to enter tweet at PC Brown myself and at
Gamespot uh with a photo of a cat as
Mega Man like go to photoshop sort of
take a helmet from one of the games draw
your own and put it on a cat cuz
basically the replica helmet is just big
enough to fit on a cat's head if you're
a really cruel owner and want to cram it
in there oh there's an e tank back
that's what I don't recommend doing it
uh yeah how would you say it compares to
the Halo cat helmet I don't know terms
Helms oh you don't have the Halo cat
helmet no I'm not a big halo fan we
could do a comparison we should do a
comparison
video between the Halo cat helmet and
the Mega Man cat helmet which may or may
not be designed for cats I would say
they're not cuz I mean the thing about
the Halo one though is that it was
called the Halo cat helmet oh really
like it was it was a helmet for your cat
make your cat look like Master Chief
gotcha uh people are asking when I'm
going to announce the winner I'm picking
Thursday as the day to announce the
winner because I will be out of the
office on Friday so uh yeah you guys
have a couple days to photoshop a Mega
Man helmet onto a cat and you know maybe
extra credit will be given to people who
Photoshop an entire scene of multiple
cats compx as characters from the series
of image we'll see uh but yeah we'll
choose favorite one on Thursday and
winner will be announced and you will
get one of those sweet helmets and they
are pretty
sweet I guess if you like Mega Man if
you don't like Mega Man I don't know or
if you like C
helmets riding this thing oh no this
time bats you may think these bats are
the Medusa's heads Master Manus is
turning a dog into Rush sorry to
interrupt you okay if you want to do
that do it but it's got to be an
addition to a Mega Man cat got to have
that Mega Man cat real stickler for the
Mega Man
cat all right now I feel like we're a
bit better equipped for the battle to
come armored
armadilla
armadilla not even look at that faster
than a speeding Energy Shot thing also I
can't switch weapons now because the
bullets are still out on the screen
there we
go get the this
time you do have the eang is back up I
do have the that's right yeah no we got
we got it this time we got it this time
would have been great is after beating
armored armadillo if Mega Man would have
run into the distance just like off into
the sunset yeah off you know outside of
that
exit out dude do it oh you jerk armored
oh you armored Dow there you
go
do that do that thing that you're
doing
oh
uh-oh there you go oh no I'm all spent
I'm all
spent all right [__]
what one more do it I'm out of bullets
okay hold on we'll we go with the ice
blast ice blast there
go ice
beam yeah yeah Ricky guitarist there was
a red helmet those were super limited
unfortunately we're not giving that one
away just a blue one but having seen
both I got to say the blue one is kind
of nicer especially if you're really
into Mega Man cuz it's the iconic One
the red variant's cool it's more limited
but does it come with a teeny tiny scarf
that you can wrap around it no it's not
a protoman helmet okay it's just a red
Mega Man helmet no it's as it's as if
you were calling you know you had Rush
the dog right so it's like rush rush
mode Mega Man right the rush armor
yeah all right so we got the rolling
Shield we're supposed to take that to
launch octopus's stage actually my least
favorite stage um also an underwater
stage coincidence I don't think so start
this do you want to play the one that I
hate yeah you want to do this one that I
don't
like launch octopus we really like Mega
Man 8 Max and I and so we like to assign
the voices from that game to Mega Man
bosses in other games oh Capcom is so
embarrassed by those voices and they
shouldn't be because they're so good
they really are wonderful brilliant
voices that are just so weird and
awkward and confusing and hard to tell
what they're saying cuz they don't
enunciate super super
good yeah like clown man I could never
understood what he was saying I'm clown
man he always said something about like
cheeky and like I don't know called you
like a cheeky
boy I think uh Aquaman was always hard
to hear too he had a really high squeaky
voice oh yeah I'm
Aquaman I know you can with the boots
though you can do the super far jump
yeah this guy he's he's a
bit might be able to do the fire no your
Fire's not going to work in this stage
actually cuz you are
underwater if you had again this is
another one if you have storm Eagle
weapon for whatever reason when you get
to this guy he's super easy the storm
Eagle's weapon will just tear through
him but we are not in that
situation whatever I can do whatever I
can
do uh Ricky guara says that you're going
to sell your red helmet on Craigslist
and then he's like if you win be sure to
bring a
knife I actually buy a lot of stuff on
Craigslist I don't do you always bring a
knife afterwards no when you go to pick
it up no cuz usually I meet at a at like
a a public neutral location oh you you
agree upon a neutral location yeah not
like hey I'm gonna come to so if he's
gonna stab you it he's at least going to
stab you in public
right wait did you not die Witnesses
against that thing I beat that thing oh
awesome I came very close to
death um but no I'm going to keep the
red one I also bought a blue one it's
not just like I bought one of each for
God damn
it um I be able to jump over I have my
own red and blue but we but in addition
to the office red and blue which
or the blue one anyway which I'll be
given away there spikes down here so
here we go oh this yep classic Mega Man
style they give you the first boss and
it's like okay I understand what's going
on and then they give it to you again
only this time everything is way
harder so he is just like trying to do
something with that search light and is
not working
out oh no oh my
goodness hopes and dreams of a nation
are with you
here thank you
Nation you can ride that up to the
surface
hurt platform up there with stuff what
can I get I don't know give me the stuff
I don't know could be anything up
there I crave stuff there's a health
pickup and a
wall I think there's a pretty sweet boat
coming up too that you can WRA which is
pretty great yeah there pretty sweet
boat I think it's right up here there'll
be yeah take this thing up take that one
take that no no either no the other one
the other
one you want to get those
crosss there's that boat there you go
right it up there wreck that
boat got to jump up there jump up on the
boat okay all right like a pirate oh you
got to Pirate that boat I have to
torrent that
boat there you go oh no you almost got
it there
you
yeah light it
up just die
already get him with the get him with
the flame weapon
fine these dudes these dudes are
wrecking your
day there you go and now you got to ride
it down you got to Surf it down like a
boss oh where we going where are we
going no you can keep going no I didn't
want to there's stuff down there what do
I got there's a there's a rather
difficult mini boss in here and then a
like a heart tank I think all right I
need to get out of this there we go ice
shotgun or yeah the lightning will be
good too you have to hit him in the head
obviously or in the tail
either you can get up on him too uh you
can ride on his
back oh there you go there you go this
eorts strats oh you
got check your check your e
tank uh maybe
start no obviously wasn't it's one of
those
buttons there you
go we got one Shield left there you go
hit the
tail he's like M you hit me
m
ice actually works really well because
you hit him with the initial shot and
then the Ricochet shots hit him in other
parts of his
body dude y he's just hanging in there
like a
boss one thing I didn't know we you
mentioned Mega Man 8 earlier so in other
versions of Mega Man 8 you can fight uh
Woodman and cutman I had no idea that
was a thing and other versions of Mega
Man 8 yeah what are you talking about
like versions that weren't the US
release I'll pull it up on are you sure
this pull up on YouTube sounds insane
I'll pull it up on YouTube right now
sounds like pure Insanity I'm all out of
my extra weapons this boss just doesn't
even care either he doesn't care he do
not he's just
like Mega Man 8
Woodman
oh the Saturn version what that's
insane insane oh I didn't oh I can't
even don't worry about you go to the
other end of the screen there'll be your
special pickup will be waiting for you
there me man Eight's like dude we've
done this before don't fight me you have
no chance to win W man's like I don't
give a damn made out of wood and I'm a
robot
I have nothing to live for I have
nothing to live for at this point my
life is a
lie people asking if the slow down in
magman X is because of the system or the
game itself well it's just the the LA
it's the system basically the system
isn't fast enough to handle it all them
Sprites oh God you have to fight another
one of these i y you have to find
another one of these yay but it was
worth it it doesn't take forever this
one's a little bit easier cuz he'll he
goes underground like this so you can
shoot him as he comes up and as he goes
under under the
[Music]
ground so you know that's something
that's something it's cool I got all day
oh you familiar with the game cheeky
cheeky boys yeah I own it oh that's
right you do people are bringing it up
in the chat a lot why are people talking
about cheeky cheeky somebody was like
have you heard about that game um um is
it because you can wall jump Auto
auto
autate says just for clarification Chey
cheeky boys was a platformer from
Genesis where you had to decide if you'd
buy better gear or
continues little known fact about random
game okay no I'm
just how did chy cheky boys come up I
don't know maybe they'll elucidate on it
in the chat feeling he's going to hit
me got to watch where he's uh he comes
out of the same place every
time thanks Capcom this is really
fun Mega Man X popular game in the speed
running Community little the little that
I know and follow of speed running I
I'll usually see like somebody be I'll
be watching a speedrun and invariably
somebody will ask like hey hey you know
I think this is pretty cool if I wanted
to start speedr running where should I
start and time and again people always
recommend Mega Man X cuz [__] there's
very little Randomness to Mega Man a
everything is with exception of some of
the bosses but everything pretty much
goes in a set pattern every single time
and if you know the patterns and are
able to execute on it you know you'll be
rewarded
um so if any anybody out there is
thinking about getting into speedr
running Mega Man X really a good place
start plus it's a classic everybody
loves it and there's tons of like if you
need any help or like documentation or
strategy or whatever the game has been
thoroughly documented and analyzed and
you are out of rolling shields for the
launch Octopus
fight could make it a bit challenging
you might say it will make it
challenging I'm pretty sure it's going
to what time we got 53 oh no yeah oh no
will we make it through launch
octopus
before the stream is
over all right which Mega Man 8 voice
does launch Octopus get ooh uh uh launch
octopus always struck me as being very
serious business um so I would think of
him is more like like a tangu
man man was pretty serious
business although he could also be a
search man because he basically gives
you search man's
weapon but personality wise I think he
really want to get into it let's really
get into
it in addition to being my least
favorite stage Lo octopus is my least
favorite dude to fight we are just spent
on all yeah we we're screwed it screwed
us it's cuz of those two those two boss
fights
man just took
forever
stre
you came up there to get me got real
serious there and it almost
worked all right let's bail on the
stage this going be our last attempt man
we got a couple
minutes do
it that stupid fire weapon and I got sub
tank I got full exit though full Escape
you
today Chris wat said we are getting
owned by lunch
octopus which is true by that he means
the hunger I have for lunch right
now
oh what's up boy hey boy boy I don't
know I don't know what that insult
was use your invisible frames
invisibility frames
no
got him got him wow what a show good job
there we go got that's that's how you
end an episode that's how you clap right
into a microphone y hope you guys liked
the
Clapping all right well I guess we're
going to end it on a high note huh we
should let's get out
before we die some stupid death
somewhere else uh so just one final
reminder if you want to win the replica
Mega Man helmet from ComiCon tweet a
picture that you photoshopped of a cat
looking like Mega Man to me at PC Brown
and at Gamespot and on Thursday we will
decide a winner you will get this sweet
Mega Man helmet uh as always Maxwell
thank you for joining me it was my
pleasure and you guys thanks for joining
us come back next week for more meab bit
and old games uh in the meantime 2
o'clock today yeah stay tuned for
multiple players multiple players at 2
o'clock Chris Waters and friends playing
games and having lives all right
everyone thanks for watching see you
next
[Music]
week